[Music]
hey everyone I'm ash Carlson and if
you've met me you know that I am a
massive massive Tomb Raider fan I've
played every single game she is like my
fictional hero I even bought an Xbox one
last year because I couldn't wait for
rise of the Tomb Raider to come out and
be us for anyway the first images of the
new tomb raider movie were released and
I got so excited for this movie I mean
it looks really in line with the video
game it's kind of following the same
plot of her continuing her father's last
journey mission but video game movies
are inherently bad example being
Assassin's Creed recently which is
played by alicia vikander's boyfriend
Michael Fassbender so the trailer
dropped last night and I decided to
completely hold off watching it so that
I could watch it right now with you guys
so without wasting any more time let's
get into it
what's your name Laura sunny
Croft alright your father's gone you can
pick up where he left off I see so much
of him in you
brilliant hello sprout if you're
listening to this then I must be dead I
found somewhere a tomb for the mother of
death if Trinity succeeds hello is in
danger promise me you will stop I
promise
I think I know where my dad went
that's right in the middle of the devil
sea it will be an adventure death isn't
haunted an adventure this is almost
shot-for-shot the game
[Music]
joke mm-hmm this is the game I love it
you shouldn't have come here but I'm
glad that you did Walton Goggins what do
you know about my father now I see the
lightness recklessness close the to once
and for the fate of humanity
they got the plane and everything this
is literally don't be too careful these
days the world has gone bloody mad I'll
take two Ernest is okay um that looks
amazing I mean it really looks exactly
like the game which could be a con I
mean I think a lot of problems with
video game movies are the pacing which
you can't really tell from a trailer but
as far as like I'm really glad I mean
they're really staying true to the
material and damn I think the only shot
that worried me really was the one of
her going under that spiky bar I think I
don't want that I don't want it to feel
too much like a video game level but
they are really following that exact
plot which if you played the game is a
really really really cool story I think
Alicia vikander looks amazing as Lara
Croft I think she's perfect for it my
final thought here is I am totally on
board I'm so sad that we have to wait
til March 2018 to see it that was really
really cool I'm glad I waited and did it
here with you guys let me know what you
guys thought of the trailer I'm so
excited I can't even concentrate Chuck
all your thoughts in the comments below
and you can tweet me I respond to pretty
much every single tweet as long as it's
respectful I'm a - Carlson Wow yes love
this I'm gonna go replay the game I'll
see you guys next time